MAX SALTONSTALL: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see how
Google enabled rapid response
to Meltdown and Spectre,
then stay tuned,
because here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Google's cloud and those
global scale traffic
and tremendous workloads, all
while maintaining security
for you and your data.
So when big security challenges,
like Spectre and Meltdown,
come around, our
architecture needs
to help us respond quickly
and adapt to these new issues.
Having the right
infrastructure design
lets us move quickly to
respond to new threats
and make changes across the
large-scale fleet efficiently.
In the last year, we had to
address new discoveries that
impacted the entire industry
appearing at the processor
level.
To start, let's dig into the
technology behind the platform
and how that creates
a secure environment.
Google's cloud technologies are
built with defense and depth
in mind, applying nine
layers of security,
starting from the hardware,
moving all the way up
to the individual people
using the platform.
For example, Google
loves containers.
And we run all
sorts of workloads,
internal and external,
in them everyday.
This is great for security
because containers provide
critical safety assurances by
isolating workloads and keeping
them from interacting
in any way.
But in some cases, the
limits provided by containers
are too basic.
So we've adopted a
two-boundary rule,
which states any interesting
code must be separated
by two defensive barriers.
That way, any one
new vulnerability
can't break our separation
between virtual machines.
Beyond our VM isolation, we've
improved on existing sandbox
technology with gVisor,
which provides security
through OS-level virtualization.
We can reduce the
vulnerability of system calls
and give us a secondary
sandbox for applications
running on containers.
This combination of strong
defenses between containers
and lightweight VM
management allowed
us to quickly update
our entire fleet
after we deployed kernel page
table isolation to combat
Meltdown and Retpoline to
prevent Spectre's branch target
injection attack.
We were able to get
to a secure state
without noticeable downtime
or performance impact,
all because we could do
live migration of VMs, patch
the underlying
processor and OS code,
then migrate the VMs back
to repeat this process again
with the next host.
Google isn't the only
one out there discovering
new vulnerabilities.
It's key that our security teams
engage with the wider security
community to share
information and fix problems
so we can all be
safer together online.
We started our vulnerability
rewards program
in 2010, which helps benefit
the security research
community through collaboration
as well as cash bonuses.
Google has paid out
almost $12 million
as of July of this year, and we
continue to improve and update
our prize amounts,
including $31,337
for a discovered sandbox escape.
Ask me later about that number.
We also think carefully
about the people and process
of securing our cloud, and
how we approach the monitoring
and response to a
security incident.
We need a strong cycle of
observe, orient, decide,
and act, with teams that
span multiple disciplines
and multiple sites
around the globe
so we can keep watch
every hour of every day.
If you'd like to
see the full talk,
check out the link in
the description below.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]